25th anniversary of the treaty on
friendship
and cooperation and the upcoming visit
of mr arrest to russia exemplifies
dynamically developing dialogue between
our two countries the two ministers will
discuss the latest developments in
venezuela and around the country
and if we will focus on containing the
spread of the coronavirus
as you know lately we have regularly
shipped russian vaccine sputnik v to
venezuela
the two ministers are to exchange
opinions on topical global and regional
issues cooperation
in the un and other international forum
our cooperation bases on strict
compliance of our two countries with
the international norms including the
sovereignty protection and
non-interference into the internal
affairs
on the 23rd of june the russian foreign
minister
is to meet the head of the ircc
in moscow mr maurer
will visit moscow and will take part in
the ninth moscow conference on
international security
during the meeting the two high-ranking
officials
will discuss the global challenges in
humanitarian sphere
uh the spread of the coronavirus and
they will exchange opinions on the
humanitarian situation in hot spots
the dialogue between mr lavrov and mr
morrow
is always constructive and substantive
and we believe that the
upcoming meeting will contribute to
strengthening our cooperation
on the 23rd of june the russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov
will hold negotiations with the deputy
foreign minister of the
of ethiopia
european deputy foreign minister will
visit moscow will pay a working visit to
moscow and the two
politicians will discuss key issues of
political cooperation
in investment trade education and
science
they will discuss global and regional
agenda
settlement of crisis situation in africa
will discuss the situation around the
horn of africa
they will also discuss the preparation
of the second russia-africa summit that
is to take place
in 2022. on the 24th
of june the russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov
will take part in the ninth moscow
security international security
conference
it is organized by the russian ministry
of defense
in his statement in this representative
forum
mr lavrov will touch upon the most
relevant
issues and challenges in terms of
ensuring global and regional
security and stability and this very day
the 24th
of june moscow will host negotiations
between the russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov
with the minister of foreign affairs of
guatemala
who will pay working visits to your
country as you know
guatemala is a promising russian partner
and we base our cooperation on mutual
respect
bilateral mutual respect of bilateral
interests in 2020 our states
celebrated the 75th anniversary of the
diplomatic relations
during the negotiations the ministers
will discuss bilateral agenda
including stepping up and diversifying
trade economic ties
deepening cultural humanitarian
scientific technical cooperation
improving legal frameworks they plan to
focus
on containing the spread of the novel
coronavirus infection
they are to exchange opinions on the
most topical international regional
topics
they will discuss the development of
dialogue between russia and the central
american integration system where
guatemala presides in the second half
of 2021. now let's proceed to
the topical international agenda
i think we should start antici with
anticipating the questions of those
reporters who are with us
we have received a number of questions
before the briefing
and there were a lot of questions
regarding the summit
between mr putin and mr biden in geneva
all
the comments have been already made by
the
leadership of our country
mr rapkov supported the statement on
strategic stability between
russia and the united states of america
we have published this information on
our websites
laying out the approaches and the
prospects in this regard
but of course everyone is interested
uh what will happen with the ambassador
of russia to the united states we expect
him
to arrive to washington next week
and although regarding all the issues
that have been set out by the president
of our country during yesterday's
press conference regarding the work of
the russian mfa
we have already started working on all
these issues that he
have mentioned now i would like to
comment
on summits and meetings that took place
in the euro atlantic area
given that the participants of these
meetings
focused on russia
we have closely monitored the g7 summit
in great britain
g7 summit took place between 11th and
13th of june and great britain
in general we understand the desire of
the leadership of g7 countries to
galvanize this format that was that used
to be important
but we also understand that it's not
easy because
g7 unites the leading
western states and mr obama ex-u.s
president
used to say that this forum
became a regional one so this is how we
should treat it because russia and china
are not part of g7
and g7 focuses nevertheless on those two
countries
although they're not part of it
however the relevant work can be done
in the g20 which unites not only g7
countries but also brics countries and
other centers of international
development
going back to g7 summit we took note
that
in order to consolidate the positions of
g7
a values oriented agenda was used it is
on this basis
the discussions were built and decisions
were made
but at the same time g7 values are not
universal
and are not shared by the majority of
international community
and i would like to take note that white
consensus is
absent even between the g7 states
regarding the values that are being
imposed by
the g7 mechanisms
it is also alarming that the g7 leaders
they draw another dividing line in the
international
affairs they call themselves
democracies and divide the world into
democracies
and on democracies and all on all the
others
g7 based on this logic
makes proposals regarding the
containment of the covet 19 pandemic
reforming of system of international
trade environment protection mitigating
climate change etc
we're not sure that this approach will
yield
positive results and will strengthen
true multilateralism enshrined
in the un in its charter
and is enshrined in principles of mutual
and
equal cooperation between all the states
regarding the discussions and narratives
on russia contained in the joint
communique
it wasn't surprising
we have read and a set of
confrontational
statements but if our colleagues
cannot talk on any other topics except
for
except about russia then of course we
cannot ban them
deprive them of this opportunity but
this anti-russian narrative doesn't
contribute
to improving atmosphere between the west
and russia
it also applies to china g7
came up with a whole list of
unscrupulous
complaints grievances
in terms of uh in as a part of western
policy of interference into the internal
affairs of
independent states this unconstructive
approach was demonstrated regarding
belarus and our other allies
which are which doesn't which do not
fall under the category of uh
countries who share democratic standards
at the same time we have heard the
desire of g7 countries to pursue stable
and predictable relations with our
countries we hope these are not just
empty words but we hope that g7
countries will
manage to underpin these statements by
concrete deeds
and on our part we favor stability
and predictability international
relations
and we have demonstrated our desire on a
regular basis
and we reaffirm our commitment to make
relevant steps based on
equality pragmatism and mutual respect
now i would like to comment on the
summit of nato
and its outcomes the nato summit took
place
in brussels on the 14th of june
the results were not surprising alliance
dreams of a global role it is
prepared to compete with china whose
desires
and vigorous actions as stated by the
native summit participants
so these desires and vigorous actions
are a challenge for the euro atlantic
when i read all this outcome documents
every year they talk about
uh threats and challenges over the years
these challenges and threats
are not confirmed
but every time i read through these
documents
through this native documents
and i i always
i will read about this challenges and
threats
that are nothing less that and imaginary
ones
so this native summit and the final
documents
were in the same logic
so we heard threats to apply article 5
on collective defense
in case an attack in the outer space and
in cyberspace
regarding the cyberspace we
hear about these threats on a regular
basis but regarding the outer space
what do our american partners expect to
see in the hours
in the outer space of course it lowers
the threshold of the use of force
it hampers security of all the other
states
and it complicates the prospect to
achieve universal arrangements
to prevent the use of the outer space in
cyberspace for non-peaceful purposes
ideologically nato wants to unite the
democratic world
countering the autocracies
including china
so apparently this is the new ideology
of nato
regarding russia the alliance
constantly leaves in a reality an
imaginary
reality we always list we always hear
about some aggressive actions by russia
which are qualified as a threat to
euro-atlantic
security the position of bloc
regarding russia remains completely
rigid destructive
and ambiguous
meaning their approach deterrence and
dialogue i wonder how it works
how it is supposed to work the leaders
of the alliance
state that over the last 25 years
nato tried to build partnership
relations with russia
they accused russia of hampering this
process violating values
principles trust commitments
that laid that are laid out in the
agreed basic documents between our
between russia and nato
they accuse us of the military buildup
of provocation activities
in the proximity of nato borders
snap large-scale exercises with no prior
notifications deployment of
w's rock missiles in the kaliningrad
region
strengthening of military cooperation
with bel russian and what's more absurd
in numerous airspace violations of nato
member states
however they ignored our proposal to
introduce a mutual
verifiable moratorium on the deployment
of medium-range missiles
they qualified it as not trustworthy and
decided not to discuss it
so it's a theater of absurd i would say
the call on russia to respect
international law
and its commitments and
if russia doesn't do it the alliance
will pursue its courts to deter our
country
among others by developing the forward
presence
program on the eastern flank but at the
same time what alliance does
they tell us
they try to persuade us that everything
that alliance does
is in line with the russian nato
founding act
they also say that the alliance doesn't
want
doesn't seek confrontation and is no
threat to russia
it's also very surprising because it is
the alliance
that draws more and more countries to it
it is nato member states who conduct
military exercises on a regular basis
not only on the territories of its
member states
but they move their military potential
and infrastructure towards the russian
border
and their total military expenditure has
already exceeded 1 trillion dollars
and it accounts for more than 50 percent
of global military expenditure
during the summit heads of state and
government of nato member states
instructed the secretary general of nato
to
review strategic conception of nato
and this conception is to be adopted on
the next summit in 2022 in spain
they hope that it will we hope that it
will reflect
the realities of today's today's world
and not the fantasies
of alliance members and we hope that
this
structure can move on from some
imaginary threats to facts but
how can nata nato do without the threat
from the east
apparently they can't do without it
they have to change something seriously
now we have received a lot of proposals
regarding
the joint communication of the high rep
eu high representative on foreign
affairs and
security policies joseph burrell and
euro commission on
the eu policy regarding russia
our source in brussels told us
the the source close to the european
institutes told us that this joint
communication
was published on the 16th of june
and we were told that this date was
chosen regardless of the fact that this
day
mr putin mr biden uh talked during the
summit
of course we familiarized with the
content of the document
and it was uh prepared by the head of
the
european uh commission on and
the committee on of the european council
it was initiated at the level of eu
leaders
of the strategic review of the
priorities of the european union
in relationships with russia we
thought that brussels would reconsider
their long-term
position in terms of the relationships
with
russia starting from the year 2016. i'd
like to remind you that
from that moment on it is built around
the
magurini principles and i'd like to
remind you that implementation of those
principles
led to the stagnation
and we can even say to the collapse of
the architecture of our relationships
this strategic reconsideration could
become the basis
to give a new start to strengthening the
stability and we know what is
positive scenario and we have
knowledge of its existence in the
european union
and in our highly competitive world
with a lot of threats transnational
challenges
we see the need for the efforts
from all sides but
what we see in the reality because what
i mentioned are just the
expectations in reality we see that the
intellectual contribution of the
european
structures does not make the
implementation closer
implementation of the
ideas to bring the positions of
russia and eu closer
we see that the author is focused on
uh the position which is uh
far from the real uh situation in russia
and they are focusing on on creating the
myth of
uh this threat coming from the east and
we
have mentioned that this is native
terminology now we are speaking about
the european union and we spoke before
that
nato has becoming more in
uh more creative in terms of
um applying various terms to this
so this is just another term that they
use with respect to our country which
has nothing to do with the real politics
of our country
now that it has anything to do with the
interests of our citizens
the number of principles in the report
about the
russia eu relationships
probably for
the leadership in brussels this is okay
but
for uh traditional diplomacy uh the
terms are not acceptable because they
use the terms
resistance containing and cooperation it
has been previously
mentioned by mr burrell during his
previous visit to moscow
and it is formulated
in line with the russorek of the cold
war
when the notorious uh deterrence was
uh led to maximum
and of course it cannot serve as the
basis for
stable relationships between russia and
the european union
and of course it cannot uh serve the
purpose to renew the relationship so
there are
a lot of contradictions in the document
we hear again the accusations on
projecting hybrid threats
towards european union about the
brussels itself
detail from the dialogue on the issues
of their concern as they say
we are ready to discuss all these issues
at any level
in any format and
appropriate time for our colleagues and
we made
this proposal on numerous occasions
unfortunately in their reports they only
mentioned their concerns
european union tries to position itself
as a monitor of international law but
they are
not taking account into account the main
package of measures
that was uh approved by the u.n security
council resolution 22 22.02
stating that eu
and this means that european union
hasn't read the
document
even though the document strictly says
that the leaders are responsible for the
implementation of the
document and they are responsible for
the influence on the
uh parties european union does not
make any influence on kiev authorities
and they are ignoring
the fact that the crisis in
relationships between russia and ukraine
has been predictable
after the application of the eu politics
of eastern partnership and their support
to the kuduthai in ukraine
in 2014.
i'd like to remind you that
the inspira those who inspired this
coup d'etat declared from the
moment one that they need to get rid of
everything which is connected with
russia its language and so on
so we recommend the european structures
before they state some
far-fetched accusations
provide the facts on
our behalf we have enough information
that
can be uh provided unfortunately we
hear no clear reaction from the european
side
european union would like to continue
making
the world in accordance with their own
partner
basing on their
own ideas which they consider the
right ones and when it is not possible
they draw the dividing lines
and sanctions
so this uh forecast this report shows
that they're not ready to get rid of
their
archaic approach and this block
confrontation
and their exclusiveness and so on
the necessity of the european union to
closely
uh follow the nato format of uh
the nato approach we are open for
cooperation with the european union and
we
stated it on numerous occasions but only
on the mutually
on the mutual basis on the basis of
mutual respect
the report states that european union
and russia are linked by the common
history and
human contacts unfortunately this stays
only on the paper
and there are no practical steps towards
implementation
of this in practice
we use the housing principles of
non-interference in the internal affairs
cooperation within the states
and implementation of the international
law obligations
our discrepancies should not be the only
fact that
is stated on our agenda
burrell burrell's report is still
important
because it shows the importance of
cooperation in healthcare and climate
and digitalization
science and technology and countering
transnational stress and challenges
their list of cooperation is close to
the one that we see appropriate for
ourselves
and we are ready to cooperate as soon
as the european union has enough will
for that
but for that we recommend those who are
responsible for the european
politics
to stop looking at these situations
through the
keyhole and open your eyes and
have a broader picture of what is going
on in the polycentric world
and to start establishing the
polycentric world order
where all interests are respected
another issue which is connected with
the european space and security issues
and this
prejudices against our country we took
note of
the
of another european leader about the
growing security threats
and when he said that
military scenarios shall not be excluded
in relationships with russia so we see
the ideology
that they apply
so this is exactly the same case because
the source of aggression for the mesagan
russia as they stated
we see lately that
there are a lot of such
statements from swedish leadership
aimed at preparing the
war with with russia and we consider
that it is
a campaign to fuel the
negative sentiments towards russia
it is clear now that the myth about the
foreign submarine
associated with the russian federation
um close to stockholm
archipelago uh so the
the smiths are not real and nobody
believes in it and that is why they
decided to
create new
justifications for the unprecedented
buildup of military expenditures
in sweden but it should be noted that
the sweden ignores uh our proposal to
renew the
relationships that has been uh frozen
since 2014 at the initiative of the
swedish side
instead they are increasing their
cooperation with nato
conducting military exercises in
the proximity of the russian border
to counter the threats coming from the
comparable
enemy including the more
trial smoke exercises of the use of
a nuclear weapon and it is
remarkable that the
against uh the backdrop of the ongoing
military exercises
uh this statement has been uh done uh
uh also uh in consideration of the fact
that
they are using a strategic bombardiers
b528
for the military exercises
another issue about the balkans the
militarization of the republic of course
is a bad idea and the idea of the united
states is to create
a certain army which is a flagrant
violation of the u.n security council
resolution
i'd like to remind you that this uh has
been a
fundamental international legal document
that
forces the withdrawal of any
kosovo and and albanian militarized uh
groups and
we call upon everyone who is not
indifferent to the
fate of balkans
to avoid steps that would be
destabilizing
and would turn into potential conflict
we are eight years away from
a sad day when the hitler
uh troops treacherously invaded our
country
and that left choices in all families in
our country and
on this day on the 22nd of july we pay
tribute to the memory
of those who were killed during that war
we still have time before that date
but i'd like to remind you
that when speaking about those
events and when preparing to celebrate
it
or
we of course think about the facts that
led to this
situation the main reason is the
aggressive plans
and manhattan full nature of nazism and
access countries politics the aggressive
plans was facilitated
by the connivance of the
leading powers of that time
to solve their own security problems as
munich agreement showed and facilitated
also the desire to
turn the vector of aggression to the
east
and in this regard it is unacceptable
to state
about certain equality of nazism and
communism
and to lay responsibility on germany and
ussr and to
make the equal and to make equal the
victims and the executors
and to silence the contribution of the
ussr
the red army liberated
the and they
did nothing that would
lead to diminishing their role in
this
did um as president putin said
uh we cannot but respond
uh to such actions and we
are going to keep the memory of those
events
and the memory of our heroes
the ministry of foreign affairs of
russia and our ambassadors
are going to conduct a number of events
to commemorate the date
taking into account the epidemiological
situations they will take place online
mostly and we
invite you to join the events one of the
event is
going to happen in minsk in breast under
the
ages of the commission of the
cooperation with compatriots abroad and
it is called 22nd of june 1941
we are to win and it is devoted to the
80th
anniversary of the victory in great
patriatic war
the participants are from about 40
countries ministers
minister of foreign affairs will
participate deputy minister will
participate in this event
mr udanku as well as the members of the
committee of the federation council
of the russian federation on
international affairs
representatives of other organizations
like uh
ross true niches and ngos
they are all going to focus on the
consolidation of the history and
education of
young people and other issues close to
the
topic they will visit the breast
fortress uh less and participate in the
demonstration
on the territory of
on this territory and now i'm ready to
take a question
international life minister
foreign affairs de coleba
minister foreign
presented his conditions for the
operation
of north stream too for russia
he proposed to exchange the gas pipeline
to crimea and also he proposes to give
to
kiev 10 of shares so that ukraine could
compensate their losses how could you
comment on this
we have a very good saying
which is pretty symbolic in this way but
um
it is also
an answer to your question and it is
about mixing apples and oranges
literally it is about business and uh
uncle in kiev and uh it shows
that there are two different
absolutely different aspects they are
being mixed and we do not understand how
mr kuleba could propose anything that
has nothing to do with
ukraine the territorial
issue has been solved few years ago
by the population of the
peninsula during the referendum
and this is the way how they evaluated
the work of kiev
authorities over all those years
of independence of ukraine
as for the north stream too
i'd like to remind to mr coleba
as well and to uh
to the healthcare regime that this is a
commercial project
and it is a profitable project for the
partners
of the project are you a part of the
project
do you wish to be one so you can express
your will and i'd like to
respond also to one more thing and to
remind
our kiev colleagues that the project
is reflecting the
mutual interest of russia
and partners in terms of the use of the
most
appropriate and beneficial route of gas
transport
so this is not about politics it's about
profit
the promotion by ukraine or by any other
countries of
uh certain pretexts or conditions to
launch and operate the
gas pipeline are violating the
principles of the
marketing and isn't it
what uh the western
communities of kiev were organized
to and so we applied their
proposal and we are implementing it as
they said
so the statement by mystic leba is
exactly
the politicization of the
situation
the partners decided to participate uh
to gain their own profit in the project
and uh while once again if mexico labor
would like to join the project
he could speak with the partners stop
this hysteria
and behave well
do you have a journalist from armenia
good afternoon
public television of armenia madame
agueron i have three questions
if i may i will respond to each question
separately
the armenian army the azerbaijan army
intervened on the sovereign territory of
armenia
and we know that they haven't withdrawn
yet
uh it has become known that the
representatives of russian army visited
the border
between armenia and azerbaijan and
discussed the possible checkpoints where
the russian
military men could be deployed in case
of
the lack of military disengagement
what's the result of the negotiations
where russia played the mediatory role
answer
russia continues to
to make active intermedia to play an
active mid-intermediary role in order to
de-escalate the situation
we work with baku with yerevan using our
mfa channels ministry of
defense border services
and the consultations on settling this
border incident
will continue we hope that
the group on the delimitation of uh
border between the two countries whether
it's further demarcation
will be launched in the near future and
we are ready to comprehensively support
this process
question on the 15th of june the
president of turkey erdogan
together with president of azerbaijan
ilham alif visited the occupied city of
sushi
it has been seven months since
azerbaijan didn't comply with
its obligations to release
military prisoners do you think that
this visit is a psychological
pressure against armenians and in other
provocations
to hamper fragile stability in the
region
answer you know we do not believe that
it is right to mix
uh the nargono karabakh issue and
bilateral relations of azerbaijan or
armenia with third countries
we believe that the bilateral con
cooperation and the region including
military cooperation must not
be pursued against any other states and
we comprehensively support any steps
that are aimed at normalizing dialogue
between baku and yerevan between yerevan
and ankara
the cooperation the south caucasus must
be based on the good neighborly
principles
and take into account all the interests
of all the countries in the region and
the last question
seven months after the ceasefire
azerbaijan authorities continued to
disregard their commitments
dated 9th november in terms of the
release of military prisoners etc
moreover azerbaijan initiated fake court
proceedings against armenian prisoners
how could you comment on this answer
the topic of military prisoners and
other detainees is very relevant
including in the context
of the implementation of
leader statements statement reached
between the leaders of russia azerbaijan
armenia dated 9th november 2020
and we welcome the release of
15 armenian citizens by azerbaijan that
took place on the 12th of june
and we favor the exchange based on
formula all for all with no
preconditions at the same time we
believe
it is important to resolve other
humanitarian issues such as demining and
the provision of
mining fields maps
[Music]
thank you do we have news front with us
yes good afternoon distinguished madam
zakharova
international media news front bulgarian
i have two questions the first question
is a bit lengthy
i would like to ask you to comment on
the statements made by
turkish president on the 15th of june
president of turkey promised to support
azerbaijan in case
the country is attacked do you believe
that this statement
is a provocative one that it fans
militaristic sentiments
despite the colossal efforts that are
being made
to return back to normal
in the region there is also was
another statement was said made about a
possible
uh inauguration of a consulate of turkey
in artsakh in the
occupied shock does it run contrary to
the peacekeeping mission of russia could
you comment on the statements why are
they being made
and what's the opinion of russia on the
turkish activities and the attempts
to strengthen their positions in the
region and i would also
i'll ask to would like to ask you about
the so-called shusha declaration signed
between
mr erdogan and mr aliyev
answer you know i have already commented
today on um a similar question i believe
that
it's not right to mix the two different
issues
one is the nagorno-karabakh issue
and another one is about bilateral
relations
of azerbaijan between azerbaijan and
third states
so in this regard we
believe that azerbaijan and turkish
contacts
at the highest level fall under the
second category
we believe it is very important
for bilateral relations including
military cooperation not to be built
against
other states and we support steps aimed
at normalizing dialogue between
the countries of the region regarding
the statements
we take into account the processes that
take place in the region
and the efforts including multilateral
efforts
aimed at striking agreements between
the parties to the conflict and aimed at
returning
to peaceful life then all the statements
that are made in this regard
they must contribute to this unique goal
that is stabilization
peaceful development recovery
economic recovery and of course
the objective the top objective must be
to support a peaceful life of the
citizens
and another question if i may
i have a question regarding the possible
accession of ukraine and
georgia to nato we have took note
that nato didn't provide timelines on
the 14th
of june during the nato summit in
brussels alliance supported the right of
ukraine and georgia to exceed the
military
block without providing timelines and
insisted on the reforms in these
countries
and the statements were made that
ukraine had to do more to reform their
country in order to exceed naita
and these statements were made on the
eve
of uh biden rush biden
putin summit in geneva on the 7th of
june
what's the russia's opinion
on the nato's position to
develop for uh to increase the
membership of the alliance
how russia will protect its interests
and security
answer i have already commented on the
natives policy
to draw more countries into the alliance
i have already commented on this topic
i can only repeat that
it is not up to
these high values that
nato allegedly pursues that is
stabilization
predictability security etc etc
these actions are counterproductive and
run
counter to these values and our position
is well known in this regard
so i can only reaffirm this russian
approach
moreover i can say that practice shows
that these statements as well as
this narrative in general was
highly uncounterproductive and led to
dire consequences
it didn't lead to any predictability
balance of interest stability and it
will not lead
to these so
these uh this is a reincarnation of a
cold war
these statements go back to the cold war
why were they made on the eve of the
russia
the us summit i don't think that they
have been specifically made to coincide
with the russia u.s summit
why can't they get rid of this
conception that reigned in the past
probably it's all about their
intellectual potential
because one historic conception must be
substituted by another one and it must
be re
reviewed renewed
it must be substituted with something
completely new
that can be proposed to the world
as a progressive way forward
as a response to new challenges
and i think that nato lacks such
intellectual capabilities to come up
with this new strategy
if they had such capabilities they would
have already
come up with another strategy
do we have anadolu media with us yes
good afternoon
adam zakarova could you please comment
on turkish proposal to ensure the
security of kabul international airport
after the withdrawal of nato and the
united states
troops from afghanistan you know that
the presence of any military contingent
in afghanistan including turkish
contingent runs counter to
an agreement signed between the united
states and the taliban movement in doha
in february 2020
this document provides for the full
withdrawal of foreign troops
from afghanistan before the 1st of may
this timeline has already been
postponed till the 11th of september
2021. the taliban movement
strongly stated its negative attitude
towards
this idea so we believe that the final
decision must be made must be balanced
based on the goals to promote process
of inter-afghanian national
reconciliation
but there is another important issue
that
we should ask
why afghanian national security forces
cannot ensure safety and security of
their international
airport i would like to remind you that
over the last 20 years
billions of dollars were spent to
increase their combat readiness
and equipment and we have heard a lot of
statements about their combat readiness
and capability to ensure safety and
security of their country we have heard
these statements made by the american
and nato officials
and now we find out that according to
nato states afghani and security forces
are not to be trusted
do we have any other issue questions
i have a question
and good afternoon the last question
i have a statement not a question
actually
don't be afraid actually i'm more afraid
of your statements rather than your
questions i'm not afraid of any
questions at all
mfa responds really quick during the
last briefing
i have asked a question regarding
compatriots
and their ability to receive residence
permits
passports abroad in russian embassies
so mfa responded really quick
the russian state duma already discusses
a draft project
in this regard thank you for not
forgetting
about our requests
and the words that are enshrined in the
russian constitution are not just
words and you implement them in practice
and together we will strengthen
will strengthen our country because
there are 20
from 20 to 30 million people who wish to
become russians
so you see that uh my friends presented
this uh hat to me i first i thought that
it says make america great again
no no it says make russia empire again
and uh
our compatriots would like to contribute
to the goal
i think that this statement is very
doubtful because
this issue was never on our agenda all
right
i can change the head well at least
this is more suitable
appropriate i will go to the biela
russian conference that you have
mentioned and i will bring three unique
books about the war
with me and i hope that our conference
will help our compatriots to be part of
this
big work that has been carried out by
the russian mfa
and by russia in general thank you do we
have any other questions
good afternoon sorry i'm on the move
but i really want to ask you one
question
a question regarding journalists
i heard that russian journalists were
not allowed to biden's press conference
yesterday
and a plane with russian journalists was
delayed in geneva
how could you comment on these
conditions that have been created for
russian journalists
could you please repeat your question
clearly
speak to the microphone please i have a
question regarding journalists
yesterday we've heard that the russian
journalists were not allowed to biden's
press conference now i
see what your question is about
the russian journalists were not allowed
to biden's
press conference and i'm happy to see
that a european journalist cares about
it it exemplifies only one thing
that all the statements regarding
openness
democratic nature the absence of
censorship of information that we
keep hearing from our american partners
so we see that these are
nothing but words behind these lofty
slogans
there is nothing and it is not they are
not underpinned by real steps
you know at the press conference of mr
putin president of russia
at the press conference of russian state
officials of different
levels of different branches of power
we invite foreign journalists to take
part in them
foreign journalists from all over the
world and when we understand that
the events
after the event there will be a press
conference
and that this press conference will
be dedicated to a certain country then
of course we invite
journalists from this country or from
this region
so we face no such problems
i think that the conclusions are evident
and a second question uh how could you
comment on the fact that
russia playing with russian journalists
wasn't able to land for 90 minutes in
geneva it was delayed
answer you know that i'm not aware of
the details so please address the
presidential executive office
thank you if we have no more questions
then i would like to say
goodbye see you next time thank you for
your attention stay healthy
you